la electricidad ha vuelto a funcionar en
libif después de que los ataques con
misiles inutilizaran cuatro estaciones
secundarias eléctricas a principios de
esta semana la empresa local de
servicios públicos está orgullosa hemos
trabajado para activar todos los
sistemas de reserva a los habitantes de
la región de elif les suele gustar
quejarse cuando hay un corte de luz Pero
esta vez reaccionar un con gran
comprensión incluso agradecieron a los
ingenieros eléctricos su trabajo pero el
funcionar con líneas de Reserva la red
está sometida a una gran presión se ha
pedido a los ciudadanos que reduzcan el
consumo para evitar los apagones en esta
ceremonia para celebrar el Día de las
fuerzas armadas en el centro del ibif
los que habían venido a mostrar su
gratitud al ejército dijeron que estaban
más dispuestos a apretarse el cinturón
solo hay una bombilla en la habitación
nos duchamos durante tres minutos como
máximo para que la Caldera no consuma
demasiada electricidad estamos haciendo
un esfuerzo
estamos dispuestos a vivir sin sin lo
que haga falta con tal de poder vivir
sin los rusos el gobernador de la región
del ibif junto con el alcalde estuvo en
la ceremonia pero les preocupa que las
buenas intenciones de los ciudadanos no
sean suficientes y está haciendo planes
de contingencia para el racionamiento
puede bajar la temperatura y algunos
residentes se encienden los calentadores
eléctricos la red eléctrica puede
romperse bajo la presión pero estos
ataques no hacen más que aumentar la
rabia de la gente y la conciencia de que
nos enfrentamos a un enemigo bajo cínico
y vilmate
a pesar de la determinación de Ucrania
de no Rendirse Rusia continúa con su
campaña de ataques contra las
infraestructuras